la chronique de l'écho comme chaque
jeudi soir claire combier bonsoir sur le
sommaire aujourd'hui de la page et qu'on
va parler restauration un petit peu dans
un instant on va parler à la
restauration et la semaine dernière le
collège culinaire de france à lens et
restaurants de qualité une appellation
pour rendre plus visibles les
restaurants qui cuisine des produits
frais et qu'il est cuisine sur place
mais avant on va revenir sur leurs
portraits de dylan presa nous avons
suivi les préparatifs de ce jeune
coiffeur pour le concours du meilleur
apprenti
il a 16 ans il est en deuxième année de
ces apps est au centre de formation de
versailles dans ce premier volet nous
l'avons retrouvé à l'un de ceux
d'entraînement puis nous sommes allés
chez lui il vit avec sa famille à magny
les hameaux un reportage réalisé avec
elodie moines et romain russe fini
il est 19 heures comme tous les lundis
après sa journée de travail dylan
s'installe dans le salon de son mentor
philippe hubert ce jeune apprenti
coiffeur ne s'arrête jamais au programme
de ce soir mise en plis et coiffure
car dans moins de 15 jours il s'apprête
à passer le concours du meilleur
apprenti au niveau régional
par contre après j'avais pensé plutôt
que j'appelle ici faire des boucles
normal
parce que ça faisait un peu flou dylan
n'est pas encore sûr de la mise en plis
qu'il va proposer car le jury évaluera
la technique mais aussi l'esthétique
alors évidemment on écoute les conseils
du coach
je leur prends
philippe apporte son aide au concours du
meilleur apprenti de france depuis une
dizaine d'années en tant que jury ou
comme cette année en tant que coach les
professeurs du centre de formation de
versailles le conseil à leurs élèves et
pour lui il est tout naturel de leur
donner un coup de main c'est notre
avenir mir du métier donc si comme on
trouve des jeunes quand on rencontre des
jeunes d'où ça qu'ils ont la volonté
d'aller plus loin que les autres et de
se donner à fond c'est c'est un plaisir
de voir ça on essaie de les aider comme
nous nous aller avant philippe conseil
dylan depuis maintenant quatre mois et
il n'est pas son unique ocz le dimanche
direction paris dans le salon délit
eliakim fin de la mise en plis et voilà
que tombe le verdict du mentor il ya des
élections tout ça s'est amélioré on va
vers un dégradé tard condamne boucle un
peu plus épaisse une moyenne d'un film
qui ont fini vous le faites au départ ce
n'est pas encore parfait mais
heureusement il lui reste encore
quelques entraînements pour fignoler il
est temps de ranger la tête à coiffer
car ces exercices ne sont pas terminées
place maintenant à la coiffure de soirée
et dylan a mis à contribution sa famille
dans le rôle du modèle sa belle soeur sa
cousine participera de son côté à la
troisième épreuve la coupe et la couleur
sur les personnes je sais qu'ils vont
pas me lâcher au dernier moment
c'est parti pour le crêpage niveau
volume ça promet
heureusement dylan encore quelques
soirées pour souffler on le retrouve
quelques jours plus tard en famille chez
lui à manille les amours mes jeunes
coiffeurs a découvert sa passion dès la
maternelle tout petit déjà il aimé
rester dans le salon de coiffure de sa
tante ses premiers cobayes sa petite
soeur et sa mère et depuis qu'il est
vraiment dans la coiffure alors là c'est
passé les conseils il faut voilà tu sais
comme si tu devrais pas faire comme ça
on fait des mèches
ses parents n'ont aucun doute sur sa
motivation pour le concours et même au
delà
comment il en parle d'ailleurs lui il
est déterminé à aller au plus haut de ce
qui peut quoi
au niveau de la coiffure et puis surtout
comment ils critiquent les coiffures à
la télévision
et si dylan est si critique et qu'il
s'entraîne si dur c'est parce
qu'intégrer un plateau de télévision et
coiffer les stars serez son rêve pour
l'instant dans sa chambre il se limite
aux têtes à coiffer mais le jeune homme
ne perd pas de vue son objectif
c'est carrément une chose qu'on fait sur
des plateaux que sur surtout des gens de
tous les jours quoi enfin après c'est
des gens qui viennent une fois ils
viennent enfin ils viennent ils font
leur couple et puis voilà que sur le
plateau enfin déjà c'est pas la même
chose c'est pas la même qualité de
travail c'est fallait les mêmes
conditions aussi et puis enfin voilà
quoi après ça passe à la télé la tension
qui règne au travail fait cool on laisse
dylan la tête dans les étoiles il est
temps de le laisser se décontracter
avant l'épreuve de ce week end
voilà pour ce portrait il y aura un
deuxième volet à suivre dès la semaine
prochaine à la lutte avec nous sur le
plateau est exactement le concours a
lieu dimanche on sera avec lui et on
verra ce deuxième volet la semaine
prochaine et on croise les doigts bien
sûr pour lui on le soutient c'est un
aiguillon courtois forcément où on parle
donc restauration à présent et une
nouvelle appellation oui l'appellation
restaurants de qualité on en parlait en
début dé me donne des missions pardon
pour rendre plus visibles les
restaurants qui cuisinent à des produits
frais c'est une initiative très
médiatisé et qui pose des interrogations
dans le milieu de la restauration nous
allons voir pourquoi pour parler de ce
sujet deux invités isabelle bianchi
maître restaurateur qui dirige l'auberge
du manet à montigny le bretonneux
bonsoir bonsoir et jean-luc mada qui est
président de la confédération des
professionnels indépendants de
l'hôtellerie
soit on sort donc on a tenté d'avoir un
membre du collège culinaire mais aucun
délai 15 chef n'était disponible ce soir
donc du coup avant d'entamer ce débat je
vous propose de regarder tout d'abord le
reportage que nous avons réalisé avec
elodie moines et qui revient sur le
débat lancé par cette nouvelle
appellation
en cuisine anthony s'attaque au turbo du
poisson frais de ce matin car dans ce
restaurant on ne cuisine que des
produits frais et du fait maison alors
je travaille au fil des saisons si c'est
la seconde du turbo ont trahi le turbo
le rouge et on travaille dur où j'ai
alors on va rentrer dans la lotte et le
rouge et on va changer un peu nos
produits quoi le fait maison un thème
qui se retrouve dans toutes les bouches
ces temps ci les 15 grands chefs du
collège culinaire de france ont lancé le
8 avril une appellation restaurants de
qualité le but rendre plus visibles les
restaurants qui proposent des produits
frais et cuisinés sur place mais avant
cette nouvelle appellation n'y avait-il
donc aucun moyen de savoir ce qu'on nous
servait dans nos assiettes des labels
existait déjà comme celui que détient la
maître des lieux isabelle maîtres
restaurateurs même pour nous
professionnels s'est séparé en août
c'est quand même reconnaissance et
beaucoup de travail beaucoup d'énergie
c'est le travail de toute une équipe
donc on est quand même assez cher un
label d'état difficile à obtenir les
critères portent notamment sur une
cuisine fait-maison des cuisiniers
diplôme et la fiabilité de la
traçabilité des produits et sur un
contrôle important un audit notamment
quand l'appellation restaurants de
qualité valide sur dossier et sur la
note des clients alors au premier abord
quand isabelle a appris la nouvelle elle
ne l'a pas tout de suite vu d'un très
bon oeil en terme d'image même si nous
mêmes en tant que maître restaurateur on
n'est pas très bien on communique pas
très bien là dessus je pense que c'est
positif tout ce qui peut mettre en avant
la bonne nourriture c'est important une
appellation médiatisé qui ouvre le débat
sur la transparence
pour la confédération des professionnels
indépendants de l'hôtellerie c'est bien
ce point qui importe mais selon elle le
fait maison les deux pas économiquement
se généraliser est ce parce que beaucoup
d'opérateurs dans la restauration et
surtout les petites et moyennes
entreprises de la dette de notre métier
pratique ce qu'on appelle la cuisine
différé ou même l'externalisation de
tout ou partie de leur production bon
bah parlons-en il n'y a pas de tabou là
dessus mais c'est vrai que dès qu'on en
parle on est immédiatement montré du
doigt comme étant des gens qui préconise
la malbouffe qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la malbouffe alors que le premier
opérateur de cuisine de restauration
commerciale en france s'appelle
mcdonald's ils ont mille 300 restaurants
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
les gens vont pas manger des hamburgers
sans la contrainte ils y vont parce que
les y trouvent leur compte laisser le
choix aux consommateurs c'est bien ce
que souhaitent tous les acteurs le
collège de france aura au moins réussi à
mettre ce problème sur la table
alors ce que ce que l'on comprend sais
c'est que vous défendez de mcdo
donc le sujet revienne voilà bravo vous
défendez donc des entreprises
américaines
son siège pour la france à guillon guy
henrot nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
effectivement j'ai été un des premiers à
accueillir dans le cadre de réunions de
professeurs de restauration le directeur
général de mcdonald's à l'époque
s'appelle philippe labbé qui maintenant
le grand patron du groupe courtepaille
est tous mes confrères étaient étonnés
que jose invité le directeur général de
mcdonald's france et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on inviterait pas dans nos tours de
table c'est un restaurateur alors
effectivement lui sa préconisation c'est
tout la gastronomie américaine bon ça
existait comme je vous le disais dans ce
reportage personne n'oblige les français
aller manger un hamburger sous la
contrainte c'est là c'est très relaxant
c'est la vérité elles existent souvent
te dire qu'on est alors évidemment
excusez moi je les ai coupés dans votre
site et
on va on va revenir un petit peu aux
lamelles brito donc tous les deux ans
vous êtes quand même d'accord sur un
point la transparence c'est oui mon
opération au feu c'est une appellation
il ya différents labels qui existent
déjà par contre sur le fait maison donc
comme comme à d'autres maîtres
restaurateurs comme le chenadec qu'il
était voilà vous avez déjà un label
disons ce fait maison oui alors le
président de l'association justement des
maîtres restaurateurs vont si c'est
rasic lui dénoncé le risque dans bond en
vieille dame à la mode les consommateurs
voilà je le cite donc vous dans un
premier temps donc ça a été coupée
apparemment montage dans le reportage
puisque vous indiquez c'est que vous
avez un peu effrayé welwyn en effrayant
mais épidermiquement quand j'ai vu ça à
la télé puisque je les ai vus au journal
de 20 heures quand j'ai vu que ducasse
et ses compagnons se mettaient à vouloir
faire un label etc on s'est dit mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est on est
encore différent va encore se
différencier par rapport au maître
restaurateur le maître restaurateur le
fait maison existe déjà pourquoi créer
un autre label qui va encore compliquer
la lisent les hits et la lecture pour le
client et après réflexion faite on s'est
dit que c'était très important quand
même que des gens comme ducasse
médiatise la restauration et que c'est
vrai qu'après avoir étudié après en
avoir parlé on s'est aperçu qu'en fait
ils voulaient tout ce qui pouvait être
médiatisé tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
parler du fait maison étaient les
bienvenus en fait parce que le votre
label maître restaurateur connu alors
ils étaient connus ils médiatiquement on
en parle très peu
les personnes qui représentent les
maîtres restaurateurs moi je les ai vus
au salon je crois que calyon aussi rhin
on a tous petits stands c'est très peu
médiatisé on en parle très peu les gens
savent très peu ce que ça veut dire donc
c'est vrai que voilà on a besoin d'être
médiatisé vous avez peut-être une
explication sur ce manque de sang est
condensée l'éducation que l'aigle
historique francis attrazic est aussi le
créateur de restaurateurs de france qui
est un label aussi il se trouve que ce
label avait pour objectif de remplacer
les étoiles tourisme dans la
restauration qui avait été supprimée par
l'administration française
le label restaurateurs de france n'a pas
fonctionné il n'a pas été plus
médiatisés que ne l'est hélas le titre
de maître restaurateur le titre métro
stater fait partie des engagements de la
profession dans le cadre du contrat
d'avenir signé par les professionnels au
moment de la baisse du taux de tva dans
la restauration servie à table en
juillet 2009 bon le titre de maître
restaurateur et des pas une invention
qui est arrivé comme ça le premier en
avoir eu l'idée avec les professionnels
représentatifs des restaurateurs c'est à
dire les syndicats patronaux c'est
renaud dutreil et sa préconisation
c'était de donner ce titre à au moins
vingt mille entreprises de restauration
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que on
reconnaissait à l'époque il y avait
plusieurs milliers de restaurateurs
capable d'obtenir par la qualité de leur
travail tant sur le plan de la cuisine
que de l'accueil que du service que huit
cadres que de l'hygiène était capable
d'obtenir ce titre de maître
restaurateur malheureusement si ça
l'aide internationale n'ont pas compris
ça comme ça et ont finalement créé un
système très réducteur et aujourd'hui il
n'y a que à peine 2000 mètres instaura
teurs ce que je trouve pas bien parce
qu'en réalité ce titre était fait pour
essayer de tirer vers le haut tout une
profession et puis très réducteur en
fait c'était malheureusement
avec à 2000 titres et c'est très
insuffisant parce que vraiment il ya des
milliers et des milliers de confrères
lui mériteraient souci alors alors
l'argument justement du collège
culinaire c'est finalement d'ouvrir à
plus de restaurants cette appellation et
avoir une meilleure visibilité sur le
fait maison finalement est-ce que le
problème c'est que ce soit fait par une
association le collège culinaire de
france parce que c'est des adhérents
militants on va dire qu'ils qui
obtiennent cette appellation et ce ne
soit pas fait par une institution c'est
ça le problème non je pense que les
jambons d'une part il faut les motiver
pour être maître restaurateur il suffit
pas non plus de dire voilà je veux être
maître restaurateur il ya quand même un
certain nombre de choses à certaines
conditions à remplir ne serait-ce que
d'en faire la demande déjà est donc bien
vouloir le faire je veux dire les
restaurateurs aujourd'hui
bas pourrait tirer vers le haut il faut
que eux-mêmes ils face à des marches au
préalable je pense que déjà c'est ça
après le fait que ce soit du cassant
collégiale et c'est peut-être que
d'autres restaurateurs auront envie de
faire partie de cette collégiale parce
que ce sera du case peut-être que le
fait que ducasse s'occupe de ça peut
être que ça ça devra d'énergie et du
dynamisme mais je me mets juste du côté
du consommateur qui ouvrait ce sens du
million qui dans les différents
établissements on multiplie les labels
les appellations et il y en a pas trop
déjà
non non je pense qu'on n'a pas trop la
preuve je veux dire il ya très peu de m
maître restaurateur et non mais n'a pas
eu un orage ça fait la différence c'est
ce que les clients par exemple qui
viennent dans votre établissement s'est
dit fier à l'avancé lorsque vous aviez
un acquis le ça parce que quand même on
la fiche je veux dire nous on le dit en
l'affichant le mets sur notre site
internet et on fait quand même partie on
a un site sur le maître restaurateur
dont il ya des gens qui sont avertis
après il y a les gens qui viennent
manger chez nous et qui sont
reconnaissants de ce qu'on fait par
rapport il n'y a pas que le titre de
maître restaurateur et à l'appréciation
du client moyen clients dernièrement m'a
dit bravo ce que vous faites c'est
extraordinaire ce qui compte le plus
c'est ben 6 convions selon lui fait
vraiment dans son match et voilà ce qui
peut avoir dans son assiette et c'est ce
qui fait que nous on peut développer en
disant voilà nous ont fait mais on est
maîtres restaurateurs on est voir c'est
beaucoup de travail c'est beaucoup
d'exigence mais dans les résultats on
parle du nombre de restaurants qui
pourrait à bord cette appellation
jean-luc madec vous m'aviez indiqué dans
une interview préalable que finalement
tout le monde ne peut pas faire du fait
maison que la majorité finalement des
restaurants d'ailleurs n'en font pas et
que ça n'est financièrement pas possible
ça me dire à moi si tu peux plus
complexe que ça dans ma part je dirais
tu sais je reviens sur votre remarque de
tout à l'heure il est sans faire trop de
labels trop d'appels ainsi dans la
première chose qu'il faut bien se dire
les uns les autres c'est que le vrai
patron c'est aussi le cas
c'est lui qui finalement choisi de venir
dans un restaurant et d'y revenir s'il
s'y est plu si un restaurateur km en
restaurateur ou pas avoir sa clientèle
déclinée qui s'interroge bon après oui
bien sûr il ya le phénomène économique
il ne vous a pas échappé que les quinze
restaurateurs qui sont en train d'être
en place à la baisse de plus ce
sont tous des restaurateurs qui sont
étoilés au guide rouge bon quels sont
les prix dans ses restaurants à moins de
100 euros hors boissons
ça n'est pas accessible alors est-ce que
ce titre là où ce label est fait pour
justifier le fait que pour aller
déjeuner ou dîner dans ses restaurants
faut casser sa tirelire et que le ticket
moyen se situe autour de 150 à 200 euros
par personne si c'est le cas
la puissance médiatique de monsieur
ducasse aura de bons résultats mais je
crains fort que c'est parce que demande
des professionnels les professionnels
dans ce métier je reviens à votre
question c'est aujourd'hui en france
80000 restaurants qui servent leurs
clients à table en région parisienne ne
sut président pour l'ile-de-france de la
confédération des professionnels
indépendants de l'hôtellerie c'est près
de 20 mille entreprises bah tout bien
considéré ce chiffre sur soissons sur 80
milles restaurants qui servent leurs
clients à table en france 60 mille
propose une cuisine ethnique
vingt mille seulement proposent une
cuisine française sur les hommes il
propose en plus une française 4000 sont
classés dans les guides et 500 ont une
deux ou trois et on va faire une cuisine
ethnique et en même temps faire
dégriffer maison mais totalement c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs je
regrette vivement que les instances
professionnelles dont je fais partie
n'est pas plus ouvert le titre de maître
restaurateur à des professionnels
capables de faire bien leur métier et
faire bien son métier c'est pas
seulement faire du produit frais faits
maison c'est aussi bien accueillir le
client c'est aussi bien revivre c'est ce
que quelqu'un sait ce qu'on veut en tout
cas le label de maître restaurateur est
l'appellation nouvellement créée alors
compris que pour ce qui me concerne je
ne suis pas tout à fait favorable à
cette pléthore de titres de la balle et
je suis plutôt favorable à ce que les
organisations professionnelles
reprennent tout ça en main et j'invite
mes confrères restaurateur à adhérer à
une organisation professionnelle parce
que c'est quand nous serons nombreux que
nous serons crédibles et c'est quand
nous serons crédibles que nous pourrons
parler à nos clients et leur dire en
toute transparence ce que nous faisons
en inscrivant clairement sur nos cartes
vous l'avez dit le patron au final c'est
le client on parle du fait maison on va
tout de même donné la parole justement
aux clients est ce que le fait maison
pour vous c'est un gage de qualité une
garantie le fait maison avez vous
confiance et l'une des questions que
nous avons posées aujourd'hui pour les
7-8
poteau oui parce que chez naïve oh non
j'ai pas confiance
on peut parce que je pense que
maintenant il n'y a plus beaucoup de
choses qui sont faites
fait maison quoi
oui j'ai confiance je pense que je vois
pas l'intérêt sinon de le marquer sur la
carte le préciser si ce n'est pas si ce
n'est pas fait maison donc oui il en or
j'ai confiance pour pas forcément si je
connais oui mais si je connais pas non
pas forcément pas parce qu'on voit
souvent des émissions à la télé qui nous
dit justement que ce sont des produits
industriels quoi ces cuisines et d'
avance non maman oui
s'écrie fait maison ça doit être celle
maison
très souvent c'est quand même des
produits achetés chez métro qui sont
juste un petit peu revu et corrigé quoi
ce que vous indiquiez on est de rebondir
là sur un sûr mais des personnes mais
trop c'est vraiment un des premiers
fournisseurs si je me trompe pas comment
les chiffres c'est le premier c'est le
premier des français pour le produit
frais donc quand on dit métro canton des
fois je n'ose même pas dire on se
fournit chez métro parce qu elle est
trop pour eux ces carrefours surgelés
enfin je sais pas quelle image ces
véhicules mais ça me fait ça me fait
sourire et pourtant c'est du frais
j'adresse faire rebondir sur le côté
prix
alors le baron d'accord alors au niveau
du prix je voulais rebondir ce qu'ils
avaient dit ce madec c'était indiqué que
le fait maison les faits maison moi je
serai juste une petite par an des jeux
serait parce que le fait-maison ses
marques et partout moi je serais plutôt
adepte de dire voilà ceux qui font pas
maison il marque devant leur porte je
fais pas maison parce que c'est beaucoup
plus âgées passeur ça fasse venir plains
ceux ci ne voient pas pourtant la russe
que 80% des gens avant d'avouer mais
dans l'esprit des gens sinon la fiche
forcément mais mais moi je serais d'avis
à faire ça c'est à dire voilà moi je
fais pas maison j'assume et je fais ou
du surgelé ou du sous vide ou n'importe
quoi je veux dire il ya du très bon
souvenir du très bon sur jeu et je veux
dire pourquoi pas mais je la fiche et
pourquoi ce sont toujours ceux qui font
maisons qui sont obligés de prouver de
sueur prouver qu'ils font mais on n'y a
pas de honte comme disait monsieur van
hecke il ya des gens qui vont manger
chez mcdo ils savent que ces congés ils
savent que les fruits de son congé ils
savent que je veux dire où est le
problème pour moi voilà et en ce qui
concerne les coûts c'est vrai qu'en
terme de en terme de
de marchandises c'est vrai que quand on
travaille à une cuisine de marché et si
c'est par rapport aux 16 ans c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup moins cher enfin je
veux dire c'est pas c'est pas très cher
par contre ce qui coûte très cher c'est
la main d'oeuvre en fait c'est vraiment
le problème du fait maison c'est à dire
que pour pouvoir faire du fait mais du
fait maison il faut avoir des gens
qualifiés donc qui dit des gens
qualifiés des gens bien payés il faut
avoir un certain nombre de personnes
pouvaient pas faire de la cuisine dans
une cuisine même pour 20 couverts avec
deux personnes en cuisine c'est
impossible voilà
si très bien votre irritation face aux
dires de toujours prouvé oui alors
j'aimerais bien revenir en fait le mode
de contrôle justement de la nouvelle
appellation qui a été notamment à ces
critiques et puisque le contrôle pour
les restaurants de qualité c'est donc
une étude du dossier par le collège
culinaire les restaurants voilant
dossier et puis chaque année c'est
réétudier ils doivent afficher 75 % de
clients satisfaits d'accord mais pas
vraiment à quoi je veux dire ce sont
quinze grands clients satisfaits qui va
ce qui va se quantifier sur quoi et par
rapport et qui m'ont donné leur avis
mais leur avis
collège d'accord alors l'histoire des
clients on à la fourchette qui est un
site où on est référencée c'est à dire
chaque client qui vient laisse une note
et il est prouvé qu'il chaussures un
petit peu long mais non les idées les
gens dit voilà je suis venu manger à
l'auberge humaine et et je donne telle
note que ce soit sur l'accueil sur la
qualité sur le service etc il faut
savoir quand même parce que j'ai lu un
article récemment sur le figaro où je
crois qu'il ya 3 % de personnes vraiment
qu'ils sont trois pas 3 3 % de clients
qui sont vraiment avisés par rapport à
ce qu'est dans l'assiette qui savent
reconnaître une langouste nar omar vous
l'avez lu l'article non vous n'avez pas
lu enfin bref que d'un buruk bien
bourguignon fait maison d'un bourguignon
pas faire et donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué de juger non pas que je fasse
pas confiance à la clientèle parce que
bon c'est toujours une une information
importante mais quand même pour avoir un
label fait maison je préférerais que ce
soient des professionnels qui me jugent
plutôt que ce soit le client lambda en
fait très haut deuxième point et finir
un peu de critiques de
de ceux restant de cette appellation
restaurants de qualité pardon c'est
aussi le fait que les personnes doivent
payer parce que c'est une association
c'est des militants c'est un euro par
jour est ce que pour vous ça vous semble
normal c'est-à-dire du madec
nous c'est pas cher s'agissant de
pouvoir être explosé avec monsieur
ducasse à la télévision génial en termes
de coûts de publicité cependant encore
une fois je pense que notre métier a
besoin de se recentrer comme beaucoup
d'autres métiers mais qui est bouche
métiers artisanaux je dirais en général
je crois que les organisations
professionnelles aurait intérêt à se
prendre à bras le corps et à faire en
sorte que tous les professionnels de ce
métier qui fasse du tout frais qui fasse
du mixte qui fasse un peu de sueur
jeunes etc se regroupent et que nous
définissions comme ce fut le cas avec
les étoiles tourisme qui on dirait quand
même près d'un demi siècle une meilleure
communication à l'affichage des
restaurants oui c'est vrai que les cm la
délégation d'écolo dit c'est quoi la
série si la solution c'est que nous
soyons tous d'accord sur un principe
c'est la transparence sur l'affichage de
nos enseignes et sur nos cartes mais
faut pas non plus de cartes se
transforme en lexique juridique
sinon on va pas s'en sortir
focal vous le disiez à juste titre rêver
un peu quand on vient dans un restaurant
où quand on lit une carte de restaurant
en même temps les italiens font ça
merveilleusement bien et ça marche sans
souci en italie où les gens sortent
beaucoup au restaurant beaucoup plus que
chez nous en france eh bien on est allé
sur toutes les cartes de restaurants la
déclinaison des produits faits maison ou
pas fait maison surgelés ou pas surgelés
est parfaitement clair et bien essayons
nous inspirait de cela sans pour autant
mettre dans nos cartes de raids ministre
hâtif ça sert pas à ça une carte de
restaurant sincères câble décliner des
produits qui sont là pour vous faire
plaisir alors après le contenu de ces
produits et bien il faut que quelques
variées attirent le père que ce soit
clair pour tout le monde il ya un gros
travail à faire je souhaite pour ma part
que ce soit les organisations
professionnelles représentatives qu'ils
fassent ce monde est pour parler ce soir
du label l'appellation ça y est
encore l'appellation restaurants de
qualité et puis on a entendu il faut que
le client le client continue de rêver
lorsqu'ils va dans les restaurants et le
client est roi après tout au delà des
mamelles et des appellations c'est le
patron merci à tous les deux clair on
passe maintenant aux enfers plus de
cette chronique oui premières infos
c'est la campagne de recrutement
yvelines étudiants seniors qui est
lancée s'agit d'une initiative du
conseil général pour rompre l'isolément
des personnes âgées dans les yvelines
150 jeunes vont être recrutés formés et
épaulé par un professionnel social des
jobs d'été d'un mois qu'ils veulent
favoriser les échanges
intergénérationnels
pour postuler les étudiants doivent
envoyer leur cv et lors de lettre de
motivation à l'adresse qui s'affiche par
non juste en dessous on parle également
renault thalès ce sont des entreprises
qui se portent plutôt bien oui voilà ce
sont des entreprises ou que innovante
qui apparaissent dans le top 100 mondial
reuters donc un classement mondial c'est
un qu'entreprise de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines y sont
présentes on y retrouve renault eads
thales snecma et valeo et au total on y
trouve 13 entreprises françaises thales
toujours qui recrutent aussi tout à fait
thales optronique que la contraction
entre optique électronique va recruter
200 ingénieurs et techniciens en 2013
ont pour une fois qu'on parle
d'entreprises qui embauchent ça mais
voilà ça change ça fait plaisir le site
emploie aujourd'hui 3000 personnes et
regroupe l'ensemble des moyens de
conception de développement des
activités donc d'optronique et
d'électronique pour les missiles et puis
après c'est l'info en plus on passe à
l'agenda
une première date pour l'agenda 5 jours
pour entreprendre c'est l'objet du stage
proposé par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines basé à
versailles du lundi à vendredi prochains
il s'adresse aux personnes qui
souhaiteraient lancer leur société au
programme des exposés des cas pratiques
pour mieux appréhender le métier de
dirigeant c'est payant mais cette
formation entre dans le vif pour plus
d'informations le contact s'affiche sur
vos écrans puis une deuxième date un
atelier les métiers porteurs sur saint
quentin en yvelines un atelier à la cité
des métiers qui aura lieu mardi 23 avril
vous pouvez découvrir la cartographie
des métiers du bassin d'emploi quels
sont les métiers recherchés les profils
les compétences les plus etc merci clair
pour cette chronique de l'économie nie
toujours complète on vous retrouve jeudi
prochain merci à nos invités également
on va bientôt terminer cette édition du
7 8